[Music]
I don't have the the easy answer for how
to have constructive dialogue online
because I though it's been you know
decade or two since the Internet has
existed it feels like like my whole life
but it's still a relatively new new
technology new phenomenon and we're
still trying to figure out I mean it's
as disruptive as the the invention of
the printing press was to our society
and how we organize and it's going to
take us time to figure out what healthy
behaviors look like in that context
that's why it's so vital to bring
together
interdisciplinary scholars and and
research across philosophical and
discipline divides that's why we're so
committed to supporting scholars who are
asking those exact questions you know
what does facilitate mentally healthy
practices online what does from a
Content moderation standpoint what
methods have led to more civil
communities and what have led to greater
breakdown all of that study is is
playing out and will continue to do so
you know I think the best that we can do
is individuals during that time is to to
tune into content like this as much as
possible you know there are some some
good there's some good advice out there
for for what we found thus far I think
it's - I was talking with a
neuroscientist Princeton trainer Oh
scientist who's now running a platform
and research center that tracks the
proliferation of hate speech online and
what was so interesting about how he was
talking about this is he was talking
about incivility and hate online as
almost a contagion like a virus like the
kind of thing that that has a definite
starting point and proliferates wildly
through basically bad digital mental
hygiene practices and we've actually
been thinking about the challenge of
intolerance lately as a philanthropy
almost like you would in addressing a
public health crisis you know how do you
so that that really resonated with me
how do you get people together who are
going to tackle a problem from a lot of
different angles how do you get
neuroscientist
together who can see how people behave
when they're becoming intolerant or
moving restorative ly to a place of
Tolerance how do you get them together
with technologists who are designing the
platforms get them together with the
conflict resolution theorists who are
seeing the models that are working in
highly fractured countries abroad get
them together with the philosophers who
are asking normative questions about how
we best flourish as human beings and get
them all to come together and figure out
what what best promotes toleration and
and peace and and what causes
degradation into that into that virus of
intolerance I think the more the more we
study it similar to how we study disease
or other major systemic problems the
more we'll start to identify common
themes common factors that lead to the
negative outcomes and the more that we
can digest those common factors into a
set of almost individual
responsibilities or best practices that
inoculate you from from those those
harmful views and and prevent you from
escalating to the point of those
behaviors that harm society and and
ultimately when we harm each other harm
ourselves as individuals
you